if you woke up every day and felt like
you don't matter and you're driving to a
job that you hate and nobody cares if
you show up or not or give your best and
you're doing work that is meaningless if
that was what you were doing every day
which I think is most people then that's
the path to unhappiness and stress and
sadness and depression and suicide
because you feel like you don't matter
but if you woke up every day and felt
like this might matter what I'm doing
today might matter to somebody if you
felt like today was going to matter you
show up with a completely different
energy and so it's not enough to do
something for yourself when you can tie
it to this is going to help somebody
else out you have so much more power and
motivation and I think that's what leads
to long-term happiness through
fulfillment